il se présente en partenaire exigeant de
plus en plus exigeants d'ailleurs du
parti socialiste jean vincent placé le
patron des sénateurs écologistes est
l'invité de préfère 3 bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous donc pour ce
rendez vous une idée de public sénat
avec dailymotion et avec l' agence
france-presse représenter ce soir par
katell prigent europe ecologie les verts
avec ou plutôt malgré ses deux ministres
réclament donc un changement de cap jean
vincent placé avec une grande première
se marrent niveau élus à l'assemblée
nationale vote comme un seul homme pour
la première fois donc contre la loi sur
l'enseignement supérieur est le
franchissement de la ligne blanche que
d'aucuns jugent inévitable quels sont
vos questions est-ce que là vous avez
franchi une ligne blanche rayée en a
déjà vu des mobilisés contre le
gouvernement de la part des des
écologistes mais là alors être tous unis
contre gouvernement oui c'est pas une
question de ligne blanche ou de lignes
rouges ou jaunes c'est que manifestement
le texte n'est pas encore arrivé à au
sénat
je ne vais pas encore préjugés bien sûr
de notre avis nous les sénateurs
écologistes on y travaillera lorsque le
texte sera dans la navette mais
manifestement j'ai pu en discuter avec
isabella tard qui était la chef de file
de nos députés à l'assemblée nationale
sur ce sujet et elle est extrêmement
mécontente ainsi que d'ailleurs
l'ensemble du groupe par rapport aux
assises de l'enseignement supérieur qui
ont eu lieu
elle considère qu'il ya un très fort
recul par rapport à la démocratie dans
les structures universitaires et de
recherche aussi un manque de lisibilité
des actions des uns et des autres une
superposition justement de ces
structures
il y a pour elle pour le groupe à
l'assemblée nationale une absence de
prise en compte des réalités précarité
ou des dimensions sociales tout à la
fois pour les étudiants pour les
enseignants pour les chercheurs enfin
dont ils sont très critiques et les
colonies voix y compris une vision
néolibérale d'accompagnement
la vision de la recherche très tournée
vers une valorisation économique je
m'engage à le préserver
vi est en flammes de l'honneur c'était
lui le terme déjà valeureux recherche
fondamentale préserver est assez
défensif et donc à la forte critique qui
prévalait à l'assemblée nationale cet
après-midi lors d'interventions
d'isabella tarn députée du calvados et
et chef de file sur le sujet était
justement cette vision donc néolibérale
valorisation économique excessive et
donc les termes étaient très très dense
alors est ce que vous pensez qu'un autre
sort est possible au sénat pour ce
projet de loi de gnf y aura ce fait il
faudrait que geneviève faure assauts
fasse davantage attention d'ailleurs à
la parole les écologistes à l'assemblée
nationale parce que pour avoir eu des
échanges directement avec barbara
pompili lac reprise en europe et
isabella tarde manifestement la prise en
compte des préoccupations des
écologistes a été très faible et de
façon générale d'ailleurs d'autres
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
indiqué que l'exécutif d'une part
c'était un peu pressé d'autre part ne
remettait pas en cause ce qui était mis
en place par notamment le madame
pécresse sauce sarkozy et dont je leur
dis et je le répète cette dimension qui
est moins tournée vers les sciences
humaines et la recherche fondamentale et
plus vers ce souci de la valorisation
économique qui manifestement est
l'impératif principale de ce
gouvernement
je vous parlais de lignes blanches ou de
lignes rouges jean vincent placé pour je
vous comprends ta question différemment
est ce que c'est une rupture avec le
pacte majoritaire nous ont sauvés moi je
répète toujours à toutes celles et tous
ceux qui s'interrogent sur ce que c'est
qu'un parlementaire de la majorité
parlementaire la majorité c'est
quelqu'un qui soutient les engagements
du président de la république et les
orientations du président public mais
les engagements qu'il a pris part les
engagements qu'il se prend lui même en
cours de mandat donc on l'a dit sur
différents sujets comme le traité
européen qui n'a pas été renégocié
non non
à cette action là lorsqu'elle ne
correspond pas à ce qu'ils sont des
fondamentaux des gauche et écologistes
de ce qui a été dit première campagne
électorale
là on voit aujourd'hui que et on sait
pas et qui sont au gouvernement que le
lobby patronal est très très fort dans
les décisions du gouvernement les hauts
fonctionnaires les technocrates dans les
cabinets et la volonté politique
l'audace l'enthousiasmé qui serait
prendre en nécessaire une vision globale
des sujets au niveau stratégique est
très peu présente donc bien évidemment
qu'il y a aujourd'hui une contestation
pas seulement d'ailleurs eux qui
montrent une des écologistes mais
j'entends le parti socialiste sur plein
de sujets vous savez on me dit ah bah
les écologistes est pas content mal
parti socialiste par la voix d'harlem
désir dit très souvent on va sans droit
de vote des étrangers sont non cumul des
mandats maintenant sur la pma sur le il
avait même proposé un référendum sur la
transparence dans la vie publique et
bien on peut pas vraiment dire que le
gouvernement écoute beaucoup
le leader du parti socialiste la même
manière les groupes parlementaires
aujourd'hui sont peu écoutés on a on
assiste à une centralisation parfois
d'ailleurs un peu confuse du pouvoir
avec je répète les lobbys patronaux qui
sont à l'action
bercy qui est très présent et puis tout
cela se fonde dans les cabinets aussi
bien à l'elysée qu'à matignon qu'à bercy
et voilà la politique qui est menée au
bout d'un an dans notre pays c est
vraiment aussi un débat la vème
république il faut absolument remettre
en cause ont lu parlement quand même
très affaibli rôle des partis politiques
plutôt des prises et peu d' écoute
manifestement des françaises et des
français
quand je vois les sondages me dis quand
même que les françaises et français on
les écoute pas beaucoup donc je crois
qui effectivement ce que nous disions ce
week-end
unanimement derrière pascal durand notre
secrétaire national nous voulons un
changement de cap économique social
environnemental
alors on va y revenir plus avant au
cours de cette émission jean vincent
placé mais au sénat par exemple
vous vous déclarez vous de votre côté
totalement opposés à la loi de
décentralisation le premier volet
arrivée pour un examen jeudi
oui les mêmes critiques ont fermé
écouter c'est pareil c'est le même sujet
par les engagements le président
république avait fait un grand discours
à dijon extrêmement intéressant sa
nécessité d'un acte iii de la
décentralisation d'une lisibilité d'une
clarté d'une densité d'une cohérence
dans les dents les compétences est
effectivement maryse lebranchu
d'ailleurs je tiens à saluer son travail
et son abnégation dans une situation pas
facile on a lancé une dynamique de
concertation et puis ensuite tout le
monde est passé
la r f l'association des régions de
france l'adf les départements
l'association des maires des grandes
villes des petites des moyennes les
montagnards les littoral
enfin bon tout le monde a débarqué on
est arrivé à un texte extrêmement lourd
ils disent ils un jour donné suite on
l'a saucissonné en trois ans qu'il est
devenu moins lourd mais tout aussi
illisible et là pour le coup personne ne
voit les mesures c'est à dire qu' il
fallait courageusement supprimer un
échelon
pour dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont parce que y compris bien sûr bien
sûr le vent de l'histoire ce sont les
régions ce sont les intercommunalités
que ce soit des métropoles des pays en
aval et évidemment qu'il fallait faire
l'effort politique radicale de supprimer
un échelon et là qu'est ce qui se passe
comme on supprime rien on rajoute encore
une mini métropole et cela sans aucune
démocratie sans aucun vote et on va
installer son heure est venue
oui les gens les gens en ont un peu
marre parce que lorsqu'on va leur dire
vous avez le département du rhône nous
avez la région rhône alpes vous avez la
mairie de lyon vous avez la communauté
urbaine et tout ça en plus on va vous
rajoutez la métropole
là les gens n'ont pu rien comprendre je
vous parle pas des syndicats mixtes des
structures intel ou bidule machin là ça
devient alors et n'importe quoi même si
je tiens à le dire
probablement que l'exemple lyonnais est
peut-être le moins mauvais des exemples
de ce qui a pu être présenté ce qui
arrive ça arrive parce qu' à paris et
croupit au de koné et ce qui est à
marseille est reportée et assez à ces
résidus allez je cherche mon motif de
satisfaction qu'on peut parler du
mariage gay dans le premier soliste
l'impressionnait levier motive sa
défense parce que vous jugez la
mobilisation des opposants on l'a vu
dimanche je ne parle pas des casseurs
il faut que ils sont toujours aussi
nombreux est ce que vous craignez un
écrêtement de la société quand on touche
bientôt cette histoire moi je suis d'une
famille plutôt tradi de normandie tout
le monde s'était marié globalement et se
sont plutôt d'ailleurs dans la famille
des gens de droite modérée et bien
personne ne crie de décrire de plus de
cris d'enfants ça apporte aux à quelque
chose d'important c'est à dire de
pouvoir officialiser un amour une vision
commune de l'avenir un engagement ça
n'enlève rien à personne et vraiment
c'est quand même beaucoup de cris pour
pas grand chose et moi j'espère que la
manifestation de dimanche bon voilà
c'est la dernière on a perdu il faut
associer la longueur et ravir les deux
assemblées
est-ce que ça doit conduire une certaine
prudence dans la suite des réformes de
société
non ce serait à mon avis d'ailleurs une
erreur politique ce serait déjà pas bien
par rapport à la nécessité de réformer
la société parce que la gauche vous
savez c'est pas le conservatisme ni le
repli c'est la réforme c'est évolué à
des sociétés parfois même anticipé pour
montrer à la société des valeurs qui
sont celles la justice de la solidarité
la tolérance de l'humanisme
du respect des autres et je crois que
c'est essentiel que la gauche continue
sa politique tarifaire l'informatrice
procréation médicalement assistée sur
les scènes lesbiennes il faut que je
suis très favorable et sur le son dans
la loi famille comme cela a été promis
par le premier ministre après la
consultation après l'avis du comité
national d'éthique et je pense aussi un
autre sujet qui avait été mis dans les
bains publics par le présent un public
lui-même c'est le droit de mourir dans
la dignité
il ya eu un rapport et le professeur 6/4
je crois qu'il faut aller au delà de la
loi léonetti trop hein oui c'est pour ça
que moi je vous en parle parce que
justement c'est serait une erreur je
voulais dit sur le fond et y compris son
plan politique parce que je le dis au
président de la république et à ceux qui
nous gouvernent et bien la gauche se
mobilise sur le mariage pour tous on
voit aujourd'hui quand même une défiance
mais on voir une méfiance de la gauche
face à la politique économique est menée
et aujourd'hui il y a quand même une
vraie mobilisation unanime enthousiaste
volontariste de l'ensemble de la gauche
et les écologistes autour de ce type de
réforme
le mariage pour tout ce qui est une
grande fierté pour nous et j'invite à ce
qu'on réfléchisse tout à la fois aux
réformes de société on vient d'en citer
quelques-unes le droit de mourir dignité
la pma et je dis aussi que nous devons
aller vers les réformes
institutionnelles la réforme
territoriale
il n'est peut-être pas trop tard pour
l'améliorer et y allait radicalement
avec justement la suppression notamment
d'un échelon on nous avons parlé du
conseil général et puis une autre
réforme institutionnelle qui avec vers
la sixième république qui a ouvert non
cumul des mandats y qui arrive à la
proportionnelle est il que nous ayons
cette possibilité aujourd'hui de
réformer profondément les institutions
françaises et on n'y va pas et ça je
pense que c'est une erreur
y compris en terme d'animation de la
majorité parlementaire et de la gauche
rassemblée il ya un autre sujet de
société c'est le cannabis jaurès en
place et avec la consommation en france
qui resta plus élevé en europe selon
l'armateur français des drogues et donc
très pessimiste très content vous le
premier sous cet angle là parce que vous
savez que c'est interdit chez nous et
nous sommes donc d'un pays où on
consomme le plus donc ça démontre que la
prohibition est un essai
est ce qu'on fait je lui ai bien il faut
légaliser nous nous portons cela deux
raisons
nous prétendons d'ailleurs est
d'ailleurs qu'avec daniel vaillant qui
lui-même pour organiser un système
public de la vente de cannabis curé donc
ainsi une transparence totale
un contrôle par les organisations
sanitaires ce qui fait qu'on pourrait
suivre celles et ceux qui fument
excessivement et tout cela ferait qu'à
la fin eh bien nous obtiendrons un bon
résultat c'est à dire la réduction de la
consommation c'est à dire que l'on est
dans un pays aujourd'hui avec beaucoup
d'idées reçues où on se dit mais ce
serait trop compliqué d'expliquer ça aux
françaises et aux français c'est pas
vrai moi je crois que les français de
français sont capables d'entendre ce
message là et là encore nous sommes trop
en retrait en décalage avec le
gouvernement non c'est la puissance je
viens de vous faire c'est celle de
daniel vaillant et je sais que françois
rebsamen par exemple été pour alléger la
banalisation est en vérité connue
montfort parce que la ligne officielle
est quand même très frileuse et au final
on a tort parce qu'en plus je vais vous
dire d'un mot un peu taquin pour
conclure ce propos c'est ce que on est
tellement bas aujourd'hui dans les
sondages on devrait faire au moins des
réformes parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne
réforme pas et en plus on est
impopulaire et bien faisons des réformes
on sera peut-être toujours aussi
impopulaire mais au moins nous aurons un
mérite de faire des réformes une
opportunité pour moi les mauvais
sondages de francs selon rémi l'idée
remonte à la heureusement on peut pas
non pas des sandales et non au devenir
avant de revenir sur les écologistes au
gouvernement j'ai une question sur
bernard tapie puisqu'on a appris
oui que son avocat et un juge arbitres
le juriste pierre restos ont été passées
en garde à vue alors étant sur la piste
selon vous d'un conflit d'intérêt qui
remettrait en cause cet arbitrage est
l'échec de l'état de 400 millions
d'euros à l'homme d'affaires
écoutez vos chimie arbitres
ni juge mais j'avais trop bu j'avais cru
comprendre comprendre mais nous aussi
nous sommes alors si c'est vrai qu'à
deux mois jean cependant je laisse je
laisse la justice faire son travail
moi je suis pour son indépendance je
suis aussi pour ceux que l'instruction
donc on voit quand même qu'il est assez
modeste et vous constaterez ça c'est un
des grand satisfecit que j'accorde au
président de la république françois
hollande c'est l'indépendance de la
magistrature et absolue et là vous voyez
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas parce que vous
auriez interrogé un responsable de l'ump
dans lequel qu'est la précédente lui le
reçu parce que il au récit qu'on serait
intervenu ou pas aux frais des
magistrats ce n'est pas notre cas
allégués telle pression donc de l'efs
mais là nous rejoint ne pourra aborder
ses relations tumultueuses on en a eu la
preuve déjà entre les écologistes et le
gouvernement une assiette c'est la
satisfaction plus grande encore que sur
les questions de société qu'on a abordé
qui pose bien sûr la question est bien
de la place de la présence durable de
vo2 ministre faustin saint geniès le ton
se durcit chez les écologistes
samedi lors d'un conseil fédéral le
parti a réclamé un changement de cap au
gouvernement pour prendre davantage en
compte les propositions des écologistes
sur la croissance l'emploi l'énergie
et pour cause les verts s'indigne de ne
pas être écouté une motion de synthèse
approuvée par les deux ministres
présents cécile duflot et pascal canfin
des désaccords oui mais pour pascal
durand pas question pour autant de
quitter le gouvernement en vertu de quel
principe on devrait être plus efficace
quand on est dans les tribunes en train
de regarder le match où quand on est sur
le terrain en train de le jouer oui nous
sommes au gouvernement
oui nous en sommes particulièrement
heureux de pouvoir agir dans le cadre de
cette majorité
mais pour autant ça ne veut pas dire que
nous devons taire ce que nous sommes une
présence pourtant remise en cause par
certains écologistes comme jean vincent
placé président du groupe au sénat face
à l'orientation sociale démocrate de la
politique de françois hollande
être ministre écologiste dans un
gouvernement socialiste
c'est aussi l'expérience de dominique
voynet ministre de l'environnement du
gouvernement jospin entre 97 et 2001
une position parfois difficile à tenir à
moins d'avoir des alliés l'opinion a été
aussi très précieuse pour éviter par
exemple des sottises comme la décision
contraire le p r le même jospin ne l'a
pas fait il eu bien raison
je l'avais d'ailleurs informé du fait
que je serai amené dans ce cas-là
quitter le gouvernement
c'était pas du chantage c'était une
discussion vraiment avec un échange
d'arguments de part et d'autre pour yves
cochet son successeur à ce poste
malgré les accords passés avec les
socialistes l'écologie reste souvent le
parent pauvre
les socialistes en général le premier
mis de l'époque n'est jospin en gros le
comprennent rien à l'écologie il en est
de même je pourrais dire actuellement du
présent de la république françois
hollande et les premiers ministres jean
marc ayrault et considère que c'est un
domaine marginal et rend domaine étant
le social international economics a fait
le chat le les écologistes attendent
surtout leur congrès de novembre
prochain
ils verront si le gouvernement a tenu
ses promesses en matière de transition
énergétique
voilà quatre questions au patron des
sénateurs écologistes allaient tout ça
on l'a entendu vous avez voté samedi une
motion de synthèse assez dur chez les
verts contre le gouvernement demandant
un changement de cap
vous avez voté contre à l'unanimité à
l'assemblée le projet de loi sur
l'enseignement et la recherche vous
menacez aussi de voter contre ce projet
de loi sur la décentralisation au sénat
ça va de plus en plus dures si c'est le
ton relations de gouvernement
je suis vous dire c'est pas un artifice
circonstancielle ou un souci tactique
qui nous anime c'est que la loi
d'enseignement supérieur recherche de
disait monsieur grossiord est mauvaise
et va dans le mauvais sens donc à nos
députés ont voté contre sa famille
éprouve alors qu'au fond la même chose
même si nous allons continuer la
discussion avec la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur sur la
métropolisation ce texte tronçonné de la
décentralisation qui est vraiment un
mauvais avatar de ce qui aurait pu être
une grande réforme décentralisatrice et
et girondines pour le coup
c'est vrai que il y en à la bombe dans
ses positions sur une poignante mais ce
que je veux vous dire c'est qu'on ne sur
ces textes là c'est pas parce qu'on
s'est vus samedi au conseil national et
que d'un coup paf on prend cet ex
taulard en otage c'est qu'on ait
travaillé comme la calandre est
maintenant et dans le calendrier
c'est ça sa marque nous avons nous
sommes déjà abstenu notamment sur la
frontière professionnels sur l'emploi en
faisant voter contre les crédits d'impôt
cette fois ci c'est à l'exceptionnelle
c'est ce que je dis ce que je me permets
je me permets d'attirer l'attention sur
ce que je dis depuis traité européen sur
la flexion sociale libérale du
gouvernement qui ait une vision assez
établies parce que souvent on dit
présent un public ne l'a pas stratégie
missiles stratégiques il s'inscrit dans
les pas du social libéralisme européens
du pse et du ppe le parti socialiste
européen qui co général que tpe le parti
populaire européen qui couleurs de l'ump
qui va pas jusqu'au bout de la
discussion politique confrontation c'est
un terme utilisé par le partage peut le
reprendre avec pas l'allemagne en tant
que tel mais avec la droite la droite
européenne parce que c'est pas
l'allemagne qui s'est altérée ça il ya
des passionnés je ne sais pas et dans
justement non c'est à dire que nous
voulons à fléchir et nous souhaitons que
le cap change on voit d'ailleurs bien
sûr les communistes qui disent la même
chose mais de plus en plus au groupe
socialiste que ce soit assemblée
nationale au sénat ya des voix qui se
manifeste je sais pas si on va parler de
de l'abandon du projet de loi soit
rémunération des patrons y arrive on y
est je vois beaucoup d'élus la police
mais vous avez entendu tout cela
semblait jour là de sa conférence de
presse il n'a pas dit qu'elle était
social démocrate il a dit je suis
socialiste
oui mais bon ils avaient dit qu'ils
n'étaient plus trois semaines avant donc
je suis content que chez dans une
émission à france 2 donc je suis content
qu'ils disent qu'il est socialiste c'est
une bonne chose et ça non voilà je suis
pas là d'ailleurs pour donner des
socialistes mais quand même malgré tout
on peut pas être dans les clous du
traité européen de des rares marge de
manoeuvre budgétaire conte à mettre 20
milliards sous crédit d'impôt maintenir
le budget sanctuariser des ministères de
la défense et de nous armer comme si
c'était
le cran le grand paradis des socialistes
aux femmes tout cela ne correspond pas d
enjeu surtout quand on propose dans le
budget qui vient d'aller sur une
tricheuse trajectoire budgétaire de
réduction encore des déficits avec 15
milliards de réductions d'impôts et
probablement quelques milliards
d'augmentation des deux parties les 15
milliards de réductions de dépenses
et c'est bien sûr nous participons parce
que nous souhaitons fait réussir
françois hollande et gouvernement et la
gauche et les écologistes après
incontestablement cette infection l'a
d'ailleurs jeudi a été décidée draw très
rapidement après le rapport gallois y
compris la tonalité ce que nous ayons
fait au collectif budgétaire de juillet
c'était pas du tout ça ce qui a été dit
d'ailleurs présent la république à
châlons en champagne a plus que moi qui
parle de ce discours mais il existe
quand même et il peut dire en gros on
n'a pas de problème de compétitivité
coût avec l'allemagne mais nous avons un
problème de compétitivité hors coûts
c'est à dire la nécessité
d'investissements un discours qui est
revenu dernièrement sur les
infrastructures de transport sur le
numérique sur la santé sur la transition
énergétique parce que là il ya des
emplois innovant moderne est susceptible
de dynamique économique et donc depuis
cette inflexion là cela implique
beaucoup de choses notamment l'absence
de marges de manoeuvre budgétaires pour
des politiques écologistes
c'est vrai que on se retrouve avec une
main puis l'investissement qui est un
bon outil mais qui est 100 brasse est un
bon outil s'embrasser à peu près la
somme les 40 milliards qu'il y avait
déjà dans oz et aux fsi et cdc
entreprises
ils nous demandent ces constats critique
oui vous demander un changement de cap
jusqu'à quand enfin à partir de quel
moment jugez vous que le cap n'a pas
changé et en groupe vous devez quitter
le gouvernement
je vais vous dire vous étiez habitué à
sarkozy que vous aimez bien sarkozy
parce que c'était simple binaire il
disait quelque chose l'assemblée et le
sénat qui contrôlait lever le bras mais
dans ces cas là je vous propose dans
votre monde idéal de la politique de
supprimer ces deux assemblées il
suffirait que le président préside
tranquillement pendant cinq ans et on
n'aurait pas besoin de ces
parlementaires mondiale de la politique
pour le préserver a comme il fallait
je pense que quand par exemple compte
comme dans une famille ces dépenses si
on aime le système patriarcal ou pas
quand le chef de famille on mène et la
famille dans le mur c'est bien que les
membres de familles disent non là ça va
pas il faut qu'on réfléchisse et qu'on
essaie de faire autre chose que le mur
sur la prochaine gold souvient des
joueurs non parce que comme les pouvoirs
de la vème république sont très
disproportionnée le président peu à peu
près faire ce qu'il veut et j'ai dit
tout à l'heure il le fait avec le lobby
patronal des technocrates de bercy est
quand même pas mal
deux personnalités qui reviennent
toujours un petit peu les mêmes et ce
soit ben on nage en plein juillet qui
est là on a mené ce sera un mec qui est
là on va bientôt nommer madame
lauvergeon enfin bon c'est pas quand
même la grande diversité ou la grande
modernité pour notre pays deux dans la
direction du pays en question et donc on
se retrouve dans dans une situation il
faut peser sur le chef de l'état pour
essayer de convaincre donc c'est ce que
nous faisons en nous répétant nos
arguments nous faisons des propositions
à ce que ce nous faisons beaucoup de
propositions dans sa transition
énergétique sur la conversion écologique
de l'industrie que soit la fiscalité
écolo et le présent un public a fixé un
cap
lui-même des objectifs pour la fin de
l'année l'a dit je vais inversée grâce à
cette politique
la courbe de chômage est un chercheur
regardons à la fin de l'année début de
l'année prochaine ce qu'il en est après
il ya un moment il faut avoir une vision
rationnelle étaient des sujets c'est à
dire que si ce n'est pas inversée à la
fin de l'année peut-être on peut essayer
une autre politique dans la mesure où
manifestement cela ne fonctionne pas et
celle que nous proposons elle n'est pas
non plus celle du surendettement
d'apolitique aux schistes du demande va
raser gratis non c'est une politique
courageuse d'investissement et de
mutation en particulier appareil
productif faire leur écologie et vers
plus vous allez rendre comme pierre
moscovici revient un peu en arrière sur
le salaire des patrons disant que je
crois qu'il a tort j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya autour justement d'ailleurs dû
d'une ligne claire
qui correspondait dit elle à une
politique à peu près mené dans les
autres pays européens social-libéral de
volonté bons de réduction des déficits
d'une volonté d'une réduction de
dépenses excessives
à côté de ça il ya différents messages
politiques de temps en temps on dit ah
je vais faire une proposition de loi
pour qu'on puisse racheter les sites
rentables
ça c'est plutôt un message leur vers la
gauche et syndicats et puis quand ça
penche de trop on fait un petit message
sur les patrons donc on leur dit aux
patrons à bannans et on laisse tomber le
projet loi sur la rémunération
c'est pas bien je pense qu'il faut
essayer de rester sur l'essentiel du
corps idéologique qui est doit être le
nôtre à gauche chez les écologistes
je sais pas je veux personne voilà ça je
sais je suis celui ci celui qui incarne
c'est pierre moscovici d'ailleurs moi je
vais vous dire je ne comprends pas le
sujet de dire qu'il ya passé d'autorité
pierre moscovici
je suis pas d'accord avec tout vous
l'entendez après je trouve qu'il a
l'autorité nécessaire pour diriger bercy
c'est pas un sujet des personnes non
mais c'est assez le fonctionnement du
gouvernement de façon globale et quelque
part le président de la république
manifestement justement tout à la fois
fait cet équilibre de sa politique
moi je pense que c'est pas assez claire
et qu'elle aurait plutôt que ce soit
culbutos et qu' il ya une ligne qui le
pensent efficace et puis il donne des
signes un peu je vous dis un peu à
gauche un peu à droite les syndicats le
patronat les productivistes un peu les
écolos quand ils râlent de trop et ça
cette façon de doser pourrait être
habile
je crois qu'elle est inadapté aux
difficultés que nous rencontrons à la
crise mondiale que nous rencontrons à la
récession européenne
et ça c'est une politique qu'on peut
mener par temps calme et sûrement pas
dans les bourrasques
il attendait que nous vivons dans un
monde aujourd'hui quand même très
insécurisant et ce plan de l'emploi et
sur le plan de la sécurité globale donc
c'est une difficulté à choisir la mer
derrière ce rapport au monde qu'il y a à
bercy
il faudrait que chacun fasse son job il
faudrait que montebourg fasse son job au
redressement productif plutôt d'aller
comme je le lis régulièrement courir
d'échec en échec 2
de florange à petroplus a good year ou à
psa est en revanche moscovici pierre
moscovici bon je suis pas je lundi dans
la ligne politique qu'il mène mais
d'évidence et je suis celle du présent
la république pour ma part je trouve que
le fair et manquera t'assure voilà il
est assumé ses salines politique et il
l'a fait d'ailleurs je trouve pour le
coup assez efficacement peut-être pour
le coup trop efficace on parle parce que
je porte pour vous vos 2 ministre
trouvent leur place au sein de ce c'est
une grande satisfaction pour nous
évidemment c'est vrai que y compris
cécile duflot avec benoît hamon est
aussi arnaud montebourg sur la ligne
européenne le volontarisme européen soit
la politique d'investissement déficit
essaie de se faire entendre comme nous
et sur le faire entendre nous les
parlementaires est également le parti
europe écologie avec le secrétaire
national vous essayez mon impression
vous soyez vraiment entendu j'en
conviens je le dis je dis que sur la
ligne directrice l'aube à la petite
polémique et sociale et écologique nous
sommes trop peu très peu entendu notre
satisfaction c'est que cécile duflot
fait un boulot remarquable au niveau du
logement
je crois reconnu de toutes et tous est
également pascal canfin qui imprime
vraiment une autre dynamique au niveau
de son secteur du développement y
compris on le voit au mali donc voilà il
ya une forme de satisfaction parce que
dans les secteurs dans lesquels on est
on travaille bien avec des gens de
grande qualité et évidemment nous
voulons peser davantage et pour qu'on
pèse davantage tout à la fois il faut
qu'on démontre que les analyses que nous
portons et sont plutôt justes
malheureusement j'ai l'impression que
nous allons démontrer à la fin de
l'année parce que les objectifs du
président ne seront pas atteints en
matière de chômage ce que je évidemment
je ne pourrais que regretter et puis par
ailleurs je le dis aussi je dis aussi
oui je le dis depuis depuis six mois
donc je n'ai pas de raison de changer
d'avis malheureusement quand je vois qui
a près d'un millier de chômeurs par jour
supplémentaire de tous de torture ont
tous ces mois depuis depuis le début de
l'année et puis malheureusement j'ai
l'impression encore jusqu'à la fin de
l'année donc
suis je suis tout à la fois déçu et je
suis de l'afa très inquiet pour la
situation économique du pays
comme beaucoup de cadres écologistes y
compris pascal canfin il ya des lignes
rouges
c'est à dire notamment la loi de
finances la fiscalité écologique qui si
cette fois sont franches ça va vous
peut-être vous paraître surprenant mais
moi je n'ai pas le temps de lire en
rouge tout ça parce que mon fil
conducteur c'est ce qui a été dit par le
président de la république et on peut
pas dire qu'il ait franchi sert son gaz
de schiste n'y a pas de sujet sur la
fermeture de fessenheim est ici engagé
c'est le discours de la conférence
environnementale au conseil économique
et social environnemental et après les
autres sujets on voit bien qu'il ya pas
de avant vegas pour la politique
écologique que j souvent c'est que le
présente plus et françois hollande
c'est pas qu'il est anti écolo c'est
qu'il est à écolo dire qu'il est un peu
sans écologie ce n'est pas un sujet qui
intéresse particulièrement et ça c'est
vrai que c'est une vraie difficulté que
nous avons soit 5 et moi public d'avoir
un président qui se préoccupent peu
d'écologie
alors on y revient merci à elle revient
donc sur ce bilan écologique du
gouvernement qui n'est pas bon à vous
suivre jean vincent placé aux enjeux
prioritaires se renier et delphine batho
la ministre en charge de l'écologie est
invitée elle est bien à se ressaisir
jérôme ramier le quinquennat de françois
hollande devait être teinté de vert
toutes les conditions étaient réunies
beaucoup d'annoncés dans la campagne
présidentielle des alliés écologistes au
gouvernement et deux groupes
parlementaires verts au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale pour peser sur la
majorité mais un an après son élection
le bilan écologique du gouvernement peut
se résumer à quelques mesures pour
l'isolation des logements
porté par cécile duflot trop peu pour
les associations de défense de
l'environnement qui commence à perdre
patience
on a le sentiment que madame bateau est
généralement le gouvernement aujourd'hui
et françois hollande n'ont pas
d'ambition environnementale n'ont pas de
politique écologique clairement exprimée
on a le sentiment que l'écologie est
encore vécue comme une contrainte et pas
comme une opportunité pour répondre à la
crise qui touche qui touche la france
aujourd'hui
peu présente dans les médias la mini
de l'écologie delphine batho est sous le
feu des critiques les associations et
l'opposition s'interroge sur sa fibre
écologique et même sur sa motivation il
ya une difficulté pour le gouvernement
portait ses projets parce que
effectivement même bateau et très absent
la sens pas très convaincu par par son
sujet et donc il ya des discours il ya
beaucoup de discours beaucoup de courbes
de travail en cours mais a peu de choses
qui aboutissent et du côté de la
ministre on demande de la patience
l'heure est pour l'instant la
concertation avant un grand projet de
loi sur la transition énergétique prévu
à l'automne je travaille je travaille
avec le soutien de la majorité
parlementaire des socialistes des
écologistes
les choses avancent c'est un chantier
très important celui de la transition
énergétique qui figure parmi les quatre
grandes priorités de la deuxième année
du quinquennat
donc il ya du boulot alors que la droite
avait à l'époque marqué les esprits avec
le grenelle de l'environnement
la gauche semble piétiner sur le terrain
écologique et beaucoup remarque que les
critiques des verts sont pourtant
beaucoup moins bruyante qu'à l'époque
aux questions sur le bilan carbone
est-ce que vous la trouvez ci transforme
que ce sera dès qu'une matoka mines et
de l'environnement
j'imagine que le mot transparente est
perçue négativement
à priori oui enfin je reprends aussi les
propos de pascal durant ce week-end
c'est au créneau faisant passer ses
dossiers je trouve qu'ils connaissent le
sujet qu'elle est compétente et qu'elle
fait ce qu'elle peut dans un
gouvernement qui je les dis avec un
présent la république qui s'intéressent
peu à l'écologie donc c'est pas évident
et c'est pour ça moi vous vous avez bien
fait un mini beaucoup de bien des
ministres oui parce que je trouve qu'il
est sympa avec des bateaux mais je
trouve qu'il n'ya pas de problème de
compétence c'est pas un preuve de
compétence ou de capacités c'est un
problème d'arbitrage et les arbitrages
c'est pas des films bateau qui fait les
arbitrages cefeo un peu au niveau de
matignon est essentiellement niveau de
l'elysée
moi ça fait cinq six mois que j'ai c'est
de décrypter comment fonctionne
aujourd'hui le des institutions du pays
oui c'est ça se passe à l'elysée avec
j'ai tout à l'heure les cinq six
personnes qui contrôlent autour du
président hollande avec monsieur m'a
conquis et le chef de l'économie avec
quelques technocrates de bercy comme
d'habitude avec la direction du trésor
du budget etc
et puis quelqu'un grands ministres qui
sont très proches du président
manifestement des bâtonnets n'est pas de
de ce passé là et les arbitrages se font
au détriment évidemment des des
pratiques écologiste a de façon infâme
ans mais on voit bien par exemple que à
chaque fois qu'il y a une décision à
prendre que ce soit sur le diesel que ce
soit sur la fiscalité écolo sur d'autres
sujets il ya une petite tendance assez
naturelle à dire ouh là là il faut
continuer l'industrie productiviste que
nous avons évolué un peu mais c'est pas
très grave et puis à yahia et si on
mettait trois centimes de plus sur le
diesel ou imaginer le chômage que ce
soit à produire car il ya une vision
extrêmement ringarde archaïque statique
de la politique industrielle et fiscales
n'ont pas ce qu'il faut faire c'est
justement ce temps de mutation et le
temps de mutation il n'est pas évident
par exemple on va peut être en parler
sur les
industrie photovoltaïque sur les
panneaux solaires les américains les
chinois et les allemands ils ont pris
courageusement la corée du sud aussi
pendant trois quatre cinq ans le pli
d'investir beaucoup y compris en
favorisant innocence et est et ça et au
départ on pourrait saisir le lin pour
former tant d'argent qui ont changé la
fiscalité est alors que on a nos
industries de charbon c'est plutôt le
cas du charbon en allemagne et nous le
nucléaire et continuons comme ça nous
nous avons une vision colbertiste et
très peu entrepreneuriale on continue
comme ça si je suis bon sens
jean-vincent placé quand on voit que
l'union européenne n'arrive pas à se
mettre d'accord dans la guerre qu'il
faudrait mener peut-être contre les
chinois
sur les panneaux celle moi je suis pas
sur le débat de mener des guerres je
pense qu'il faut juste avoir une équité
et un équilibre dans les moyens et c'est
pour ça que d'ailleurs je soutenais la
position de taxes et de 47%
les panneaux solaires qui viennent de
chine mais ça c'est un débat plus
globale sur les normes environnementales
et sociales et sur le fameux européenne
banque ait que président sarkozy
d'ailleurs avait essayé d'initier comme
débats pendant la campagne
présidentielle parce que il nous faut
absolument protéger nos industries
oui moi j'ai une vision l'écrivain
régulation
exactement c'est à dire que ce que je
reproche arnaud montebourg c'est ne pas
avoir vision écologique est dommage
parce qu'on version parle de temps en
temps et de plus en plus de lui
peut-être pour prendre la tête d'un
grand ministère de l'environnement en
cas de remaniement ça maintenant je
crois que ce serait la provocation
ultime c'est à dire de m celui qui
défend depuis un an
vaille que vaille le nucléaire et des
gaz de schiste dans notre pays qui court
après toutes les activités productiviste
et polluantes comme j'ai dit de
petroplus à florange est à pessah à vous
dire de m quelqu'un est tout à fait
compétents et sympathiques et de mettre
celui qui est peut-être le plus anti
écolo de ce gouvernement au ministère de
l'écologie vous cherchiez à nous parler
de faire une ligne rouge ce serait une
provocation qui pourrait devenir une île
rouge la réserve circulent
c'est une rumeur c'est ici moi j'entends
ça c'est pas moi qui décide et je le dis
ce serait une provocation qui pourrait
devenir une rouge ou même si il s'agit
de diviser en deux par exemple la
citadelle de bercy en mettant l'écologie
sur la tutelle de l'industrie de chez
moi j'ai très clairement à jour un
changement de politique mais je ne veux
pas de remaniement donc comme ça
continuons comme cela avec ce
gouvernement avec le premier ministre
qui par ailleurs aussi je trouve aussi
est quand même assez solide dans la
tempête et quelque part entre le nombre
de ministres un peu turbulent et qu'une
majorité complexe à gérer et avec un
président qui intervient peu surtout je
trouve que le premier ministre au final
est peut-être celui qui est l'élément
aux stabilisants équilibrée et solide de
la majorité je pense pas qu'ils aient
besoin de remaniement et surtout n'ont
pas de monsieur montebourg à l'écologie
l'offensive menée la semaine dernière
par certains industriels européens
notamment par jamais être à l'aise au
moment du sommet européen sur l'énergie
pour apaiser le débat il ne faudrait pas
justement un grand débat national sur
cette question des gaz de schiste non
mais on peut faire tout le débat qu'on
veut nous mais nous faisons le débat
nous faisons pas de façon sectaires ne
l'ayons nous l'avons eue avec monsieur
nous l'avons vu rémy sur fion mais nous
sommes aussi fermé que monsieur fillon
monsieur jacob monsieur copé qui
lorsqu'on a posé la question 2011 c'est
eux qui ont fait la loi qui parce que
c'est pas la gauche qui a fait la loi
assez à droite qui a fait la loi
peut-être était ce dû au fait que les
fameux gisement compenser productif
était en seine et marne mais je pense
pas que c'était le sujet essentiel et je
crois que même fillon copé sade et
rassemble et jacob s'était rendu compte
que ya un problème des gaz de schiste
d'une part on sait pas la réalité de ce
qu'il y a d'autre part on envoie les
millions de mètres cubes avec des
produits chimiques parfois cancérigène à
15 km au sol avec la fracturation
hydraulique mais il ya un autre élément
que je trouve incroyable que qui ne soit
pas dans la pensée de monsieur
mestrallet au d'autres c'est que si aux
états unis ça marche et encore
des économies qui s'est disputé en
pologne en recul en recul on a commencé
à faire des petits travaux recherche et
puis on commence à reculer
il faut faire un puits tous les
kilomètres 5 toutes les 8 minutes il
faut faire un puits il faut élargir les
roues pour faire passer les camions qui
vont chercher tout ça donc aux etats
unis quand il ya six habitants n'est pas
concevable qu'il va mettre des grands
espaces vierges aux états unis avec une
tradition agricole qui est liée à
l'énergie ce qui fait qu'un en gros tout
le monde a son ranch et tout le monde a
son puits et mais nous on va faire ça
avec nos 110 habitants par kilomètre
carré
c'est totalement absurde et quand vous
aurez votre petit puis à côté de chez
vous avec le méthane qui sort ou mettez
un petit briques et hop ça fait du feu
ce très content d'avoir les enfants de
côté mais vous savez les américains dans
massachusetts qui sont cotées aux
hippodromes en avoir ras-le-bol mettra
évidemment ça des tanks et de forme de
société il ya des questions qui se
posent en matière de facture énergétique
pour les entreprises la compétitivité
énorme qui se creuse entre les
industries sus aux états unis
l'industrie européenne
d'un point de vue compétitivité comment
l'industrie européenne peut suivre nous
avons aujourd'hui 70 milliards d'euros
d'importations de pétrole et de gaz
parce que ya pas que le débat gaz de
schiste nucléaire et énergies
renouvelable
aujourd'hui quand on dit 75% de
production d'électricité c'est pas la
production énergétique on apporte 70
milliards qui déjà pour des questions de
balance commerciale de déficit de
balance des paiements des nécessités
écologiques de nécessité de
compétitivité l'énergie renouvelable
c'est essentiel même si à la limite on
est pour le nucléaire
il faut absolument investir sur les
énergies renouvelables parce que vous le
savez l'environnement va réduire les
marci
la différence qui existe entre
l'industrie entre l'industrie américaine
l industrie européenne qu'est ce que
vous dites vous aux salariés des
industries françaises qui perdent des
marchés parce qu'ils sont moins
compétitifs que certaines autres la
sécurité actuellement actuellement et
c'est vrai une réalité économique le
coût du nucléaire sortie mais c'est hors
assurance or démantèlement hors
investissements et recherche qui
notamment été palpé pays par le public
le coût de sortie actuelle est un peu
plus bas aujourd'hui que le que le
renouvelable
mais c'est pas ça qui fait la différence
la preuve comme nous nous sommes mauvais
en termes de maîtrise de l'énergie et de
consommation nous avons à peu près la
même consommation si le prix actuel est
à -20 à -25% par rapport à l'allemagne
sauf que l'allemagne consomment beaucoup
moins donc en réalité on équilibre
donc vous voyez que la question de la
maîtrise de la consommation
ta question aussi de la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments et de toutes les
questions d'isolation et le fait de
faire la diversité dans les ressources
parce que je rappelle quand même que ce
que nous prônons de fait même si nous
sommes pour la sortie du nucléaire au
plus vite possible
c'est l'accord que nous avons entreprise
à la république qu'il a réaffirmée de 75
à 50% programme nucléaire qu'on fasse
monter les rôles accorde et
photovoltaïque solaire biomasse biogaz
il ya des énormes potentiels ainsi que
les éoliennes donc voilà cette vision
diversifiée et pour le coup assez
pragmatique en réalité parce qu'il faut
dire que les écologistes fondamentaux
fondamentalistes ils nous disent ah mais
vous êtes vraiment trop mou et c'est
jean vincent placé une dernière question
est-ce que créer est ce que vous
craignez pardon que la tentation
mélenchon existe chez les électeurs
europe écologie
vers qui seraient déçues de votre
participation au gouvernement non je
crois pas je ne suis pas moi un
défenseur acharné des des sondages parce
qu'ils ont parfois disant pas ils ont
parfois ils se trompent
mais le dernier dont personne ne parle
bizarrement sur les élections
européennes le louis harris qui donne
23% je crois de mémoire à l'ump 21 au ps
18 malheureusement front national et 10
à europe ecologie les verts démontre
justement notre stratégie que nous
assumons da d'être dans les
responsabilités courageuse parce qu'il
serait beaucoup plus facile dans la rue
et de brailler comme jean luc mélenchon
mais nous assumons cela nous assumons
notre dans les institutions y compris
quand il peut y avoir une part
d'impopularité et en revanche je crois
qu'on fait avec courage et conviction
parce que c'est pas si facile que ça on
dit ah bah tiens il passe à la télé pour
critiquer gouvernement que ce qui n'a
pas le critiquer non là je pense que
c'est important pour le pays que nous
changions de politique économique
sociale écologique bien vous l'avez dit
les changements de cap eva joly a défilé
avec jean luc mélenchon n'est ce pas
périnet ce qu'elle aura une place sur
les listes d'europe écologie les verts
aux européennes où rim ou non jeu ça a
été notre candidate
à l'élection présidentielle je trouve
qu'elle a dans un climat très difficile
bien porter notre parole qui sont
importants avec notamment le thème de la
fraude fiscale de lehman christiane
s'entend et musique ont rigolé à ce
moment là on voit à quel point c'est
important
et bien moi je souhaite qu'il continue à
nous aider politiquement et je souhaite
qu'elle soit sur nos listes aux
élections européennes ça me paraît bien
naturel
voilà c'est dit merci merci jean vincent
placé bonsoir à tous et à très vite la
semaine prochaine mais ce n'est pas
notre rôle
les ministres d'agriculture sera notre
invité
la posture et ya très longtemps et j'ai
pas eu de réponse du tout ensuite j'ai
fait quelques petites unités pro stature
de cdd qui n'ont rien donné non plus ils
sont jeunes ils sont pleins d'avenir et
ils sont au chômage durant plusieurs
mois ils se sont filmés dans le
labyrinthe de la recherche d'emploi un
parcours semé d'embûches avec ses cours
moral ces petites déceptions et ses
grandes victoires pas merci pas sur la
cohésion tout cas mon dos et ça qui va
me plaire donc je suis vraiment content
en bouche moi si tu peux
samedi à 22 heures sur public sénat
ans
regardez cette vue paris paris dans
toute sa splendeur pendant trois siècles
et bien ce panorama des rois des reines
des empereurs l'on contemple est scruté
par fois depuis la terrasse d'un des
plus prestigieux château de l'histoire
de france
bonjour à tous et bien ce château celui
de saint cloud n'existe plus c'est
l'histoire qui l'a détruit et seule la
végétation trace aujourd'hui encore son
architecture disparu
paradoxe c'est un hobby français qui la
détruit dans cette période trouble et
souvent oubliés de la guerre de 1870
tout s'est passé très vite le 13 octobre
de cette même année une année maudite
une année terrible
marie lebon juillet 1870 française et
prussiens entre en guerre une guerre de
mouvement rapide et brèves aujourd'hui
oublié ses origines restent confuses et
pourtant quelques épisodes demeure dans
la mémoire collective
la bataille de gravelotte près de metz
oppose huit mille cavaliers français et
prussiens la capitulation de sedan qui
entraîne le 2 septembre la chute du
second empire et l'exil de napoléon iii
et plus tard la perte de l'alsace et de
la lorraine lors de la signature de
l'armistice à versailles en janvier 1871
autre conséquence immédiate le
chancelier bismarck et ses troupes
encerclent la capitale c'est le siège de
paris les parisiens trouvent refuge à
l'abri des fortifications
mais très vite les pénuries alimentaires
se multiplient on manque de tout dans
les eaux des jardins on abat les animaux
pour se nourrir et pour survivre c'est
des terrasses du domaine de saint-cloud
que l'état-major crucien observe le
siège un quartier général à portée des
tirs des bastions français l'obus fatale
par du mont valérien et enflamme le
château après avoir été pendant des
siècles le théâtre de l'histoire
saint-cloud disparaît dans les flammes
sous le regard impassible des forces
prussienne
je rejoins inciviques glaser qui est
administratrice du domaine national de
saint-cloud bonjour madame
alors il n'y a plus aucun doute
aujourd'hui a pas de querelles
d'historiens c'est bien un obus français
qui a frappé le château de saint-cloud
ah oui tout à fait l'obus qui a été tiré
le 13 octobre 1870 provenait du mont
valérien est tombé dans la chambre de
l'empereur et ils étaient bien fiers
français alors vous a conduit un petit
mot de la situation de cet ancien
château paris est vraiment tout proche
mais versa il n'est pas loin non plus
bref c'est un endroit idéal pour un roi
une reine ou des empereurs
oui alors c'est vrai que saint cloud et
étaient entre paris et versailles
on passait on s'arrêtait à saint cloud
en allant voir le roi ou au retour et ce
n'est pas pour rien d'ailleurs que
c'était la résidence du frère de louis
xiv
philippe d'orléans on l'appelait
monsieur a beaucoup a grandi cette cet
ancien pavillon de chasse
il ya une autre personnalité extrêmement
attachés à ce château de saint-cloud
c'est marie antoinette
oui alors en 1785 marie-antoinette
acquiert le château de saint-cloud comme
biens personnels
elle y passera son dernière était elle
recevra la faye est auréolé de ses
succès de la guerre d'indépendance aux
états unis et y aura aussi une entrevue
beaucoup plus je dirais se crêpent qui
est l'entrevue avec mirabaud
il yal empire l' empire qui a marqué cet
endroit déjà le premier empire en tout
cas ses prémices le 18 brumaire c'était
ici à quelques mètres seulement dans
l'orangerie qui existait alors
exactement là effectivement bonaparte à
l'époque attendaient dans les halls elle
dans une des ailes du château
les deux conseils étaient réunis conseil
des anciens dans la galerie apollon du
conseil des cinq sens dans l'orangerie
qui fait donner la garde les autres les
députés qui étaient tous en toge se
précipite à l'extérieur et quelques-uns
un peu un peu tétanisé bt finalement
veut presque otage on va dire proclame
aussi la démission du directoire
bref essai le considèrent qu'ils
commencent qui commence ici en tout cas
quasiment exactement le château de
saint-cloud c'est également le
coeur le coeur battant du second empire
en quelque sorte napoléon iii alors
napoléon iii a été proclamé empereur par
le sceau natus consulte dans la galerie
d'apollon et ce n'est pas un hasard
puisqu'il voulait effectivement
s'inscrire dans la tradition du premier
empire
on évoquait à l'instant la destruction
de ce château de saint-cloud en octobre
1870 le château qui restait en ring
pendant des années après pendant plus de
20 ans effectivement la troisième
république hésite sur l'avenir à
réserver à cette ruine belle héroïne
quand même si le château a été
finalement démoli en 1892
c'est aussi une décision politique il
est trop chargée des souvenirs de la
faillite de lempire chargé des souvenirs
de l'ancien régime dans cette pour cette
république encore en corner santé
vacillante
c'est un risque politique qu'elle n'a
pas envie de prendre parce que
finalement la destruction de ce château
de saint-cloud et sa non reconstruction
ils coïncident grosso modo à l' incendie
de des tuileries à paris des tuileries
qui elles aussi n'ont pas été
reconstruits oui alors en 1883 les
tuileries sont rasés en 1892 cinq lots
et razel